es hora de trabajar con el problema
número 16 y seguramente estás lleno de
ánimo igual que yo o será la taza de
café que acabo de tomar no lo sé pero
hagamos el problema número 16 que tiene
un camino muy parecido a éste así que
tomemos la herramienta de camino y
vámonos de aquí para acá ok
algo de aquí para acá después de aquí
para acá ok y después de aquí para acá
ok y nos dan algunos datos como este
punto este punto le llaman am a este
punto le llaman ven a este punto le
llaman sem y por último a este a este le
llaman de perfecto y qué datos me dan
bueno me dicen que la distancia de a abm
son 16 kilómetros de aquí acá hay 16
kilómetros perfecto y debe hacer hay 15
kilómetros hay 15 kilómetros y desea de
hay 4 kilómetros 4 kilómetros muy bien y
ahora sí que me dice el problema el
problema me dice lo siguiente
cuántos kilómetros se ahorraría dalia
dalia es la que está siguiendo este
camino sin viajará directamente de aaa
de ok entonces cuántos kilómetros se va
a ahorrar dalián si lo que hace es un
camino directo lo voy a poner con este
color con color azul de a ave lo que
quiero es este camino o dicho otra
manera esta distancia para ver cuánto se
ahorrarían comparándola con la distancia
que hizo dalia ok ahora para resolver
este problema hay dos formas de hacerlo
la primera es decir bueno en la
distancia de aquí acá es x y de aquí acá
es 15 menos x y utilizar que estos son
triángulos rectángulos este de aquí este
de aquí y cambiando la herramienta ésta
también de aquí ok
esa podría ser una forma de resolverlo
sin embargo creo que si sería un poco
difícil tal vez difícil no es la palabra
más bien creo que tendríamos que hacer
muchas cuentas y nos llevaría una
eternidad resolver este problema hace
rato que estaba viendo este problema
una idea estupenda para resolverlo y
fíjate bien muchas veces lo que tienes
que buscar es encontrar la forma más
fácil de resolver un problema y no
quebrar te tanto la cabeza quiero que
veas el siguiente rectángulo y justo
aquí está la clave si me tomo este
rectángulo de aquí este de aquí ok
este rectángulo va a cumplir ciertas
distancias este lado va a valer 15
kilómetros este de aquí también va a
valer 15 kilómetros ok y éste éste va a
valer 4 kilómetros 4 kilómetros porque
estamos hablando de un rectángulo y
seguramente te estás preguntando para
qué nos sirve un rectángulo justo
ahorita pero date cuenta que acabo de
encontrar un triángulo rectángulo
sorprendente este nuevo templo
rectángulo me va a servir para resolver
el problema
fíjate bien este triángulo rectángulo si
el dibujo esta recta si el dibujo para
acá otra recta y yo dibujo una recta de
aquí para acá este triángulo rectángulo
el triángulo rectángulo de color salmón
es el que me va a importar basta
para resolver este problema porque
porque yo sé que este ángulo es de 90
grados
sé que es de ángulos de 90 grados porque
este es un rectángulo y además qué datos
tengo bueno que uno de los catetos este
de aquí vale 15 kilómetros ok por una
parte pero este otro cateto de aquí
hasta acá vale cuanto vale de aquí hasta
acá en distancia de aquí está acá
bueno pues son 16 kilómetros más 4
kilómetros lo cual me da 20 kilómetros
perfecto entonces tengo un cateto de 20
kilómetros otro de 15 kilómetros y lo
que quiera obtener es la hipotenusa la
distancia de un ave y como obtengo la
hipotenusa en un triángulo rectángulo
utilizando el teorema de pitágoras y el
teorema de pitágoras nos dicen que la
hipotenusa al cuadrado es lo mismo que
uno de los catetos al cuadrado más otro
de los catetos al cuadrado ok pero ya
tengo los dos catetos del lujo de la
hipotenusa al cuadrado es igual a uno de
los catetos elevado al cuadro
el otro de los catetos elevado al
cuadrado y está del lujo porque ya tengo
los dos catetos es decir que la
hipotenusa va a ser igual la hipotenusa
al cuadrado va a ser igual a 20 que es
este cateto elevado al cuadrado más 15
que es el otro cateto elevado al
cuadrado más 15 elevado al cuadrado pero
los padres de todo este problema es que
cuando yo no tenía este rectángulo de
aquí el problema parecía ser un poco
difícil o tal vez bastante largo pero si
yo pienso y encuentro este rectángulo de
aquí ya la hice lo único que necesitamos
es resolver esta ecuación que tengo aquí
que realmente no es nada difícil porque
porque la hipotenusa elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 20 al cuadrado lo cuales
400 más 15 al cuadrado 15 x 15 es 225
225 ok o dicho de otra manera la
hipotenusa al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 625 o podemos decir que
la hipotenusa es decir la distancia que
hay de a
es lo mismo que la raíz cuadrada
positiva porque estamos hablando de una
distancia de 625 y la raíz cuadrada de
625 es 25 tú no puedes creer o lo puedes
intentar por ti mismo 25 por 25 te da
este es uno de los cuadrados clásicos ok
25 al cuadrado me da 625 y no sólo eso
ya tengo la distancia que hay de adem la
distancia que hay de adén son 25
kilómetros 25 kilómetros y ahora si
puedo comparar la distancia que hay de
aaa de manera recta haz la distancia o
la trayectoria que hizo dalián dalia
recorrió primero de ave 16 kilómetros de
ave recorrió 16 kilómetros ok y después
recorrió desde hace 15 kilómetros debe
recorrido 15 km para el norte ok y
después de shehadeh recorrió cuatro
kilómetros de shehadeh recorrió cuatro
kilómetros ok y cuánto suma esto bueno
pues la distancia que hay en esta
trayectoria me va a dar 16 más 15 más 4
lo cual es lo mismo que 20 35 35
kilómetros ok si italia hace el
recorrido de abc de sea de hace 35
kilómetros pero si se va directo de de
recorre 25 kilómetros por lo tanto puedo
concluir que si usted va directo de aaa
de dalia está ahorrando use 10
kilómetros y esa es la respuesta de este
problema 10 kilómetros que por cierto es
el inciso c es el inciso c y esta es la
respuesta de este problema recuerda que
los problemas del s ate tiene de hacer
muy sencillos por lo tanto trata de
buscar la forma fácil de resolverlos
vayamos al siguiente problema problema
número
17 y bueno también cabe mencionar que
dalia no puede teletransportarse deja de
volar y aparecer de entender
forzosamente tiene que seguir una
trayectoria de adén y la más corta es en
línea recta ok problema 17 uno de los
círculos tiene un radio de un medio otro
de los círculos tiene radio de 1 cuál es
la proporción que hay entre el área del
círculo grande a comparación del círculo
pequeño ok entonces tengo un radio de un
círculo grande de un de una unidad de un
centímetro un metro de lo que sea y
tengo un radio de un círculo pequeño de
un medio ok de un medio de kilómetros o
de millas lo que sea si yo quiero
calcular el área de este círculo grande
cuánto va a ser pues el área del círculo
grande es lo mismo que pi por radio
elevado al cuadrado y por uno elevado al
cuadrado lo cual por cierto es para ok y
si aún pienso en el círculo pequeño pues
me va a quedar que el área del círculo
pequeño es la misma fórmula y x
al cuadrado lo cual me quedaría pi por
pero radio vale un medio entonces por un
medio elevado al cuadrado y esto es lo
mismo que pi por un cuarto por un cuarto
ok
porque estoy calculando estas dos áreas
porque lo que me pregunta el problema es
cuál es la proporción que hay entre el
área del círculo grande lo que quiero
comparar es el área del círculo grande a
comparación del área del círculo pequeño
del área del círculo pequeño y bueno
cuál es esta proporción pues podemos
sustituir ya sé cuánto vale cada una de
estas dos áreas el área del círculo
grande vale pib y por otra parte el área
del círculo pequeño vale pi por un
cuarto pi por un cuarto por un cuarto ok
esto lo pongo así porque este con este
se puede cancelar y esto no está
diciendo que es lo mismo que uno entre
el cuarto uno entre un cuarto cuando
canceló el valor de pie arriba y el
valor de pie abajo y uno entre un cuarto
es lo mismo que la ley del sar
entonces es este por este entre este por
este y esto me va a dar a cuatro sobre
uno o cuatro pero si esto lo vemos
hablando de proporciones lo que me estoy
refiriendo es que el círculo grande es
cuatro a uno el área del círculo pequeño
el área del círculo grande es cuatro a
uno en el área del círculo pequeño que
por cierto está en mis respuestas como
el inciso de la respuesta de este
problema es el inciso d y ya están de
lujo problemas 17 vamos al problema 18
aunque el problema 17 estuvo
relativamente sencillo y tengo ganas de
ser el problema número 18 que dice si la
suma de puros enteros consecutivos puros
enteros consecutivos desde menos 22 a x
el 72 cuanto vale x perfecto
si tú has estado al pendiente de todos
los vídeos de seattle
seguramente recuerdas este problema este
mismo problema lo resolvimos hace tiempo
en algún vídeo de la siat y de hecho
creo que hice dos vídeos acerca de la
solución de ese problema no recuerdo
bien lo que recuerdo es cómo se resuelve
este problema y lo que recuerdo también
es que este problema tiene una trampa
para resolverlo vamos a ver quiero sumar
todos los enteros consecutivos desde
menos 22 después le voy a sumar a esto
menos 21 y después le voy a sumar a esto
menos 20 y así lo voy a seguir sumando y
sumando y sumando hasta llegar por
ejemplo aquí al cero y después voy a
seguir sumando y sumando y sumando aquí
tengo al 1
aquí tengo al 2 y así me voy a mantener
sumando sumando y sumando hasta llegar
por ejemplo aquí al 20 aquí al 21 aquí
al 22 y después voy a seguir sumando y
sumando y sumando y sumando sumando
hasta llegar aquí
ok voy a sumar todos los enteros
consecutivos hasta llegar a x y además
sabemos que el valor de toda esta suma
que tengo aquí es 72 ok y esa vez en ese
problema nos dimos cuenta que aquí hay
un montón de números que se cancelan y
se cancelan porque estoy sumando por una
parte números positivos y por otra parte
números negativos por ejemplo aquí voy a
sumar 22 y aquí voy a restar 22 por lo
tanto cuando suma 22 y después resta 22
estos dos números se van a cancelar
podría hacer las cuentas puede sumar
menos 22 menos 21 menos 20 lo que tú
quieras pero después voy a sumar 20 21
22 y por lo tanto se van a cancelar los
valores de estos dos pasa lo mismo con
21 21 se va a cancelar con menos 21
menos 20 se va a cancelar con 20 menos
19 se va a cancelar con 19 y así no
puedo seguir y seguir y seguir hasta
llegar al menos 1 y el menos 1 se va a
cancelar con el 1
al menos 2 con el 2 y aquí tengo el 0
pero sumar 0 es no hacer nada por lo
tanto también lo puedo cancelar por lo
tanto como la suma de todos estos de
todos estos de aquí hasta acá la suma de
todos estos me da 0
entonces para llegar a 72 realmente lo
que estoy haciendo sumando 23 más 24 más
algunos más hasta llegar a x y esto me
tienen que dar 72 lo que me preguntan es
el valor de x cuál es el último número
que estoy sumando todos estos se
cancelan y para que me dé la suma 72
tengo que sumar algo por aquí y que
sigue después del 22 el 23 el 24 y así
hasta llegar a x y esto tiene que ser
igual a 72 pero para no complicarnos más
la vida vamos a ver cuánto nos da la
suma de 23
a las 24 aquí van como 47 ya esto es 125
aquí me dan sesenta y tantos vamos a ver
cuántos la suma de estos veintitrés
24 más 25
la suma de esto me da 3 y 4 7 y 5 12 y
llevamos 1 1 y 2 y 2 y 2 me da 7 72 de
lujo que es lo que yo quería 23 más 24
el 72 o dicho de otra manera x es igual
a 25 que es el último número que sumó
para que me dé resultado 72
realmente me estaba tomando la suma de
al menos 22
más menos 21 más menos 20 más
así todos estos todos estos todos estos
más 20 21 y 22 más 23 más 24 25 y la
suma de todo esto te puedo apostar que
es lo mismo que 72 y ya está aquí está
la respuesta de este problema que en un
principio sonaba muy rimbombante ok
déjame quitar esto de aquí y vamos a
poner ahora el problema número 19 o no
de hecho voy a quitar el problema número
19 porque no creo que me dé tiempo de
hacerlo me he quedado sin tiempo y lo
mejor es que lo haga en el siguiente
vídeo hasta la próxima